I think the word business
it becomes the business but what you're
doing is you're you're you know painting
a pitch you're you're you're you're
trying to you're trying to create create
something to make a difference to other
people's lives you have a blank canvas
and you're filling in in every little
bit of that canvas to get every single
little detail right and and if that
canvas you know sings out at you at the
end and it's you know it's a beautiful
picture you your business is going to be
successful if you know if bits of the
canvas are not quite right your business
may fail so if you set up to change
people's lives you've got to get every
single little detail right and you got
to make sure that the people that you're
working with a hundred percent believe
in what you're trying to do and you've
got to you've got to make sure that what
you're trying to do is it's worthwhile
spending your time on and at the end of
the day you want to be sure that you
know that the people's lives you've
affected you've really been it you have
it affected them and benefited them and
you know if you get all that right you
know hopefully you'll be able to pay the
bills at the end of the year
life is short life should be fun but if
if the the chairman of the company is
having fun you know if you go to a party
and you know if I let my hair down and
I'm the first to be throwed in the
swimming pool and and I'm not just
sitting there standing in the corner of
the room sipping sherry or something
then everybody I'll have a laugh and
everybody having fun you know if you're
gem to come buddy be the first to dance
on the table you know just get everybody
else up dancing on the table and make
sure the parties you know the parties
are laughs so you know so play hard and
play hard work hard and then and you
know follow certain principles in life
you know be you know you know love
people make make sure you make a
positive difference in this world while
you're on it you just watched two
amazing clips with Sir Richard Branson
take the next three minutes and sit
quietly and think about how you can
apply them to your business and your
life believe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]